before our monologue tonight we have
some very sad news to share with you
fox news cameraman his name was pierre
zakszewski he was killed yesterday in
ukraine during an attack that also took
the life of a 24 year old local
ukrainian journalist named sasha who is
helping fox news as a consultant in the
country the attack also seriously
injured our very own fox news
correspondent benjamin hall tonight
we're all praying for benjamin's speedy
recovery we're paying praying of course
for the families of pierre and sasha and
benjamin as well please keep them in
your thoughts and prayers with us now
because of these brave journalists we
know what's really happening in ukraine
this is now becoming scorched earth an
unprovoked russian invasion of a
sovereign country no one is safe
according to russia's ambassador to the
u.n this war will not stop until all of
putin's special military operations are
achieved in other words until all of
ukraine is smoldering and leveled to the
ground that appears at this hour to be
the goal now sadly ukraine is likely
just step one for vladimir putin who
knows what his territorial ambitions
hold but he has them the only question
that we have tonight is will in fact
vladimir putin uh is he capable
you know of going into the baltic states
is he going to go to moldova or georgia
who knows
would nato even have the courage to
fight back i cannot confidently give you
an answer to that question tonight this
is a critical time for the u.s and the
world we must make life miserable for
vladimir putin and those carrying out
his orders he needs to think twice
before plotting another invasion his
military's got to be neutered his bank
accounts drained his ability to wage
long-term war limited nato and western
european countries they must immediately
and forever end their dependence on
russian energy making putin and russia
rich again and by the way i'll add we
shouldn't be importing oil from the
muellers in iran we shouldn't be begging
opec nor should we be begging the
murdering thug maduro in venezuela
without getting into world war iii we
should never put boots on the ground in
this situation but there are other ways
to stand up to vladimir putin and we can
do it we can do it all right now with
lethal aid to ukraine we should be
supplying a continuous uh supply of
weapons munitions what they need that
includes javelins that includes stinger
missiles and yeah joe biden should not
have vetoed the mig-29 fighter jets that
poland offered a plan that biden
personally decided to kill didn't want
to anger vladimir unfortunately i have
zero faith that your government will
ever make the right decision in this
case our top three leaders in this
country that are elected are completely
and totally utterly out to lunch you
have the disaster that is the weak frail
cognitively struggling joe biden then
the disaster and train wreck that is our
vice president kamala harris we have
long documented all of biden's struggles
on this program we have also documented
kamala harris's struggles on this
program perhaps she's even worse and
then over the weekend kamala harris of
course as everybody knows told the crowd
that ukraine was a nato member take a
look
so i will say what i know we all say and
i will say over and over again
the united states stands firmly with the
ukrainian people in defense of the nato
alliance
now the white house will later stealth
added her transcript to correct the fact
that false nato reference to take it out
after those remarks and our humiliating
trip abroad the administration bench
kamala harris for the foreseeable future
it's been one disaster after another for
her now president biden is saying you
know he will somehow make his way to
europe for the nato summit next week
like kamala harris that's a predictable
disaster joe will be very tired from his
long trip meanwhile back here at home
okay who's the third ranking elected
official
the third in line to be president that
would be 81 year old nancy pelosi and
she now appears to be completely
malfunctioning herself if you think
option one is bad and option two is bad
option three may be worse watch for
yourself you decide they know that we
can't go there uh
putin is trying to
bait the trap so that
we go in and that's the beginning could
be the beginning of world war iii uh
putin totally irresponsible using
weapons that are not allowed under the
geneva connect convention putin who
threatens chem use of chemical weapons
nuclear and the rest so they know that
we can't but it's the ask now
he was uh this morning
more
let's if we can't have an if we can't
have a no-fly zone let us
have our own and we need the airplanes
to come in this morning he was
less on the
on the ask for the um
that policy more on let us do it help us
get the planes but also there is a
school of thought that thinks the
anti-aircraft
missiles and the rest are a very
important way myself when i see that
that those tanks at 40 miles of tanks
i'd like to take out those tanks i mean
i i think that
them having more planes might be useful
but that i'm not a
military
strategist
we hope that we will be able to get up
to a place i hope you asked me how i i
hope that we can get to a place where
the
migs which are the kinds of planes
they've been framed on
can go to ukraine
the f-16s especially if we have an
excess of them
can backfill for poland
it's sad to have to state the obvious
but between nancy joe and kamala harris
this country is not in good and capable
hands putin the world i can see are
laughing at all three so-called leaders
of this country god help us all but
congratulations no more mean tweets
america you got what you wanted as
kamala harris said this weekend like
many of you millions of americans across
the country they miss a president who
was willing to tell the cold hard truth
would tell it with conviction and
strength and fortitude and have the
ability to fight back and fight back
hard remember when president trump
reprimanded germany for their dependence
on russian oil and gas back in 2018 he
also lectured the head of nato well at
least one world leader is finally a
little late but finally singing a
similar tune take a look
we're protecting germany we're
protecting france we're protecting all
of these countries
and then numerous of the countries go
out and make a pipeline deal with russia
where they're paying
billions of dollars into the golfers of
russia it is vital uh if we're gonna
stand up to putin's bullying if we're
gonna avoid being blackmailed by putin
in the way that so many western
countries sadly have been
we've got to get ourselves off russian
hydrocarbons countries in
nato namely germany having a large
percentage of their energy needs paid
you know to russia and taken care of by
russia now if you look at it
germany is a captive of russia vladimir
putin over the last uh years has been
like a pusher uh feeding an addiction uh
in uh western countries to his
hydrocarbons uh to his oil and gas uh we
need to to get ourselves off that
addiction
now two years late for boris and late
for our nato allies and western european
allies as he's now begging the saudis to
pump more oil saudis aren't particularly
happy with joe biden right now because
he's trying to do this deal brokered by
vladimir putin uh with iran which is the
dumbest idea in the world we'll get to
that in a second but president trump was
right then he's right today the world
refused to listen